[Musique]
lorsqu'il fait 23 degrés à lille
forcément les terrasses sont pleines et
pour trouver une place il faut savoir
être patient
ici il y à plus d'une demi heure de
queue pour pouvoir s'asseoir première
chose de soleil donc eh ben on sort
c'est tout on a réussi à trouver une
table on va pas la lâcher
les médias font de la prostate regardes
tu regardes les journaux de 20h et
cetera mais c'est de la propagande à
tout le monde est content les terrasses
sont rouvertes quel bonheur tout le
monde est souriant rouvert tandis on
dirait les infos de pyongyang
qu'est ce que c'est que ces conneries je
dire c'est tout ça ces mythes au complet
s'est il faut arrêter les médias doivent
arrêter de faire de la propagande il
faut qu'ils informent les gens de
manière objective
depuis le 19è ce que vous avez un
incident oui ou non en terrasse non pas
gentil juin je suis je me suis fait
mordre par une dame six équipes qui
voulaient pas payer
j'avais oublié j'avais oublié la mort du
visage est encore la marque
j'ai envie de dix mille questure dr jose
ramon pourra vous poser des questions
quand même elle était très exubérant
n'était que ça n'avait pas payé
non elle est accompagnée d'un charmant
artisans taxis pour qui vous avez
beaucoup à l'étranger et qui je salue
déjà elle avait 45 ans
même profil de la vie qui a insulté et
sert non mais vraiment c'est une plaie
la paye est finalement alors lui est
venu payer parce qu'il avait tellement
honte je suis très tranquille on s'est
vraiment nous assurerait dans votre
émission vous n'êtes pas tranquille vous
venez à vent venait enfin de discuter
tranquillement avec les gens j'ai la
gentillesse de répondre à vos questions
vous êtes arrivé comme ça comme un
seigneur comme si le moment non mais
comme si un moment comme si au moment où
vous arriver là il faut que tout
s'arrête parce que vous avez une caméra
et un micro bonsoir chers voisins on
vous voit wola droit coucou génial le
contact est établi et bien grâce à vous
énerver
on se réconcilie avec le voisin et on
peut dire merci à hervé ton pote
immersive où elle passera t il avant de
sortir n'ai pas pris un verre n'aura
hélas mal pour un mec qui génère tout
jamais comme ça
la ville nommée raison
non c'est bon frère ça me permet déjà
vous enlevez le relever en lever votre
perche ce qu'il ya dans la caméra il ya
dans la caméra dix cas dans la caméra je
crois que la n1 la haine la haine ne
sera pas guéri avec la un mail à 1,2 se
guérit avec l'amour non mais ces
attentes ont ça c'est important ça moi
je crois que la question à poser c'est
pourquoi tant de haine
huit cent quarante mille personnes
interrogées sur leurs habitudes de
sommeil ainsi que sur leur potentiel
troubles dépressifs résultat les lève
tôt au moins de risques de faire une
dépression c'est même très précis selon
les chercheurs une personne qui a
l'habitude de dormir 6 heures toutes les
nuits et qui reculerait l'heure de son
coucher qui au lieu de se coucher à une
heure du matin se coucherait à minuit
réduire s et risque de dépression de 23%
ça t'a fait flipper moment toutes ces
histoires de kovy d'autres de ces
tristes parce que les gens sont dans un
sens c'est bon c'est pas bon dans un
sens on au compromis au comprend
maintenant ce que c'est la liberté
vous êtes allé en chine
on a fait tout le littoral chinois mais
en particulier on a chanté à ou à wuhan
à guangzhou à tout ça il a chanté one
une et moi j'ai pas tellement eu peur du
comité j'essaye de l'ignorer et c'est un
avis un investissement c'est le dernier
avertissement je crois de la nature la
nature nous réserve bien des surprises
et celle là est de taille
regardez ces images une maman calais ces
petits marche tranquillement au milieu
des voitures
cette scène insolite s'est déroulée
jeudi dernier à strasbourg en plein
centre-ville en enseignant à
immortaliser ce moment à toi qui se
décide pas les jeter à l'eau
regardez un jet de poulet qui a été mis
en vente sur le site d'enchères ebay un
morceaux de poulets frits d'une célèbre
enseigne de fast food comme on dit à la
télé qui a atteint la somme regarder
deux cent mille dollars ses 92 1080 2000
euros mise au prix au départ 99 centimes
heures le vendeur espérait 50 $ regardez
comme il est bien emballé pour être mis
en vente comme c'est appétissant
l'idée pour cette saint valentin un peu
spécial chouchou pense qu'on va se faire
un fast-food sur la table du salon comme
on peut faire d'habitude mais moi j'ai
vraiment envie de rendre ce fast-food
romantique
donc je pars sur l'idée de faire une
jolie table
je sors la vaisselle des grands jours je
verse le soda dans les verres à vin
je mets les petites sauces dans des
petites coupelles voilà je joue le truc
jusqu'au bout si un internaute a
déboursé plus de 82000 euros pour
s'offrir ce morceau de poulet frit
c'est parce qu'il a la forme d'un
personnage du jeu vidéo une longueur le
très cher nuggets acheté dans un
fast-food aux états unis a été vendu aux
enchères sur ebay après plus de 180
offres une transaction délirante que
certains aimerait bien reproduire au vu
des très nombreuses annonces similaires
publiées ces derniers jours
jeff bezos le patron d'amazon vient
d'annoncer qu'il s'envolerait dans
l'espace le mois prochain à bord du nil
shepard
le faisceau de sa compagnie blue origin
voir la terre de l'espace ça vous change
un homme
ça change votre rapport à la planète à
l'humanité il n'y a qu'une planète terre
je veux faire ce vol parce que c'est un
rêve d'enfant c'est une aventure qui
représente beaucoup sur moi tu sais rien
de faire des jonglages en imposante et
ans a absolument aucun intérêt la balle
et monte mais redescend jamais donc pas
pareil pour les tirs pareil pour tout ça
écoute chez pas qu'ils viennent si tu
serais très heureux ici je sais pas si
tu as envie d'aller dans l'espace mais
en tout cas ce sera pas pour jouer au
football ce serait incroyable jeff bezos
s'est si confiant dans son projet qu'il
sera le premier à le tester pour un
volume 1 il sera accompagné d'un
équipage de pilote et astronaute d'un
passager payant après une vente aux
enchères et a proposé à son propre frère
devenir aussi comment ça on change de
lutte j'ai pas compris c'est ainsi que
ce fort c'est la nouvelle miss
galvao bah moi je connais rien les trucs
à la nouvelle lune en fait je comprends
pas pourquoi jean nouvelle lune sachant
qu c'est toujours la même depuis 101 ans
c'est comme la marée basse pendant